this video is kindly sponsored by
warpath find out more later in the video
hey 42 here on a crisp autumn day in
1994 diane doozier took a bite out of a
warm cheese toastie
it wasn't a particularly remarkable
mouthful just two slices of white bread
and some american cheese
and yet ten years later this same
sandwich
sold for 28 thousand dollars
why
well according to duzia this was no
ordinary toasty in fact it was nothing
short of a message from god himself
because
burnt into the sandwich's starchy
surface
was the face of the virgin mary
for 10 years duzia kept the sandwich by
her bedside looking at it for religious
guidance and good luck in times of
trouble after a decade she nobly decided
it was time to share her sacred snack
with the world
slightly less nobly she chose to share
the toasty by selling it to the highest
bidder on ebay
where it promptly became one of the most
viewed auctions in internet history
receiving over 1.7 million hits
the toasty was finally bought for 28 000
real american dollars by golden
palace.com
an online casino famous for its unusual
marketing schemes
the toasty joined the company's curious
miscellany of peculiar purchases
alongside the 25 000 kidney stone of
william shatner
and the 650 000 naming rights to the
recently discovered madidi titi monkey
the monkey's official latin name
literally translates to the calicebus
monkey of the golden palace
but don't worry this video isn't another
one of
elaborate advertisements what we're
really interested in here is that cheese
toasty not because it was chosen as a
quirky conduit for a genuine message
from the man upstairs
let's face it
that will be mental
but because it's one of the many strange
spiritual sightings documented across
the world from mother teresa's
appearance in a cinnamon roll to the
face of a grinning devil in the queen's
hair on a 1950s canadian banknote in
2002 thousands of christians traveled to
bangalore to pay homage to a stale
chapati
which appeared to bear the face of jesus
christ god's eldest has also been
spotted in a fish stick a cheeto the
flames of the notre dame cathedral
and even the water-stained plaster from
some guy's bathroom
which sold for nearly two grand
are all these sightings really examples
of divine intervention
the short answer is
no
probably not
god may well work in mysterious ways but
if he's taken to doodling on toasties
and graffitiing bathroom walls with his
son's face
then quite frankly we're all the
ability to identify and read human faces
is an essential skill our ancestors
evolved millions of years ago facial
expressions are one of the most
universal methods we have for social
interaction they allow us to quickly
understand and respond to each other's
motives and make snap decisions about
potential threats that could
literally be the difference between life
and death
do you know what else can be the
difference between life and death
the power of the air force which has
changed history and the face of modern
warfare
wait a minute
we have breaking news from warpath our
military base in the english channel is
under heavy attack send out
reinforcements
don't worry our air force is invincible
for those of you who don't know warpath
is a free-to-play mobile strategy game
based on the heroic battles of world war
ii
warpath is free to download on google
play and the app store allowing you to
experience real modern warfare right on
your mobile anytime anywhere as for me i
enjoy warpath for a number of reasons
but mainly because the game
realistically recreates the armies tanks
warplanes and classic battles that
existed in world war ii now thanks to
warpass recent update you can experience
realistic modern air force warfare
altogether there are 42 new fighter and
bomber units for you to unlock to help
you defeat other players fighters
see
i told you our air force was invincible
the introduction of the air force in
warpath creates a more realistic and
overall just a more challenging war
experience
so you can dominate the sky
win the war
also junk lord van damme has now arrived
in warpath with unimaginable munitions
and generous reward packages find him
in-game to unlock exclusive commanders
and aircraft units so are you ready to
join the fight well if you click on the
link in the description to download the
game now and use my code air force 2021
you will instantly get 200 gold 100k
military funds steel crude oil and army
experience you can use these resources
to build your base and gain an advantage
in the coming war it's evolutionarily
favorable to have an overly sensitive
recognition system
rather than one that's not sensitive
enough the decision to run away from an
orange flower that looks a bit like a
lion's face
is probably a better option than going
up to smell a lion that looks like a big
orange flower
as a result our brains are primed to see
faces everywhere around us even when
there are no true faces to be found
this phenomenon is called facial
paradolia and as you can see from the
many memes and web pages dedicated to it
it's pretty common
just have a look at the twitter hashtag
i see faces but our fascination for
faces far outdates the emergence of
social media
in fact the first known evidence of our
attraction to face like formations can
be dated back nearly three million years
to a single pebble
known as the machicans gap pebble or the
pebble of many faces
this ugly lump of rock was found
alongside the fossilized bones of one of
our early ancestors a good 20 miles from
the nearest known source of this type of
rock suggesting an early hominid
stumbled across the object and
drawn to its face like features brought
the personable pebble home of them
kind of like a prehistoric wilson from
castaway
what we do know is that our interest in
things with faces lives on to this day
for a start there's a whole museum
dedicated to rocks with face like
features in japan obviously
called the hall of curious rocks
another rock that's fascinated us for
centuries is the moon and perhaps the
most universal experience of facial
paradolia is the appearance of the man
in the moon although the exact position
of his face is disputed others argue
that the dark shapes on the moon
actually mark out the shadow of a
celestial moon rabbit that spends its
days pounding away with a mortar and
pestle grinding up herbs and making rice
cakes for the gods
because we all know that the gods love a
rice cake when they aren't busy tagging
toasties but what's going on in our
brains that causes us to see these faces
when we look at an object the image we
see isn't really the object itself but
our brain's interpretation of light
waves bouncing off that object's surface
this light enters our eyes and is
focused on the retina which converts the
information it receives into neural
signals and sends them onto our brain
most objects are recognized by an area
of the brain near the back of our heads
called the lateral occipital complex
this region processes objects in terms
of their parts
for example when you look at this image
your lateral occipital complex will be
making sense of each individual root
vegetable arranged artistically in a
shiny black bowl
but if we flip the image the once
innocuous tub of tubers suddenly bears a
striking resemblance to the hogwarts
gamekeeper wearing a black winter hat
a different part of your brain the
fusiform face area has just kicked into
action
unlike the lateral occipital complex the
fusiform face area processes objects as
a whole by analyzing spatial
relationships as well as the objects
themselves
it forms a much more holistic
interpretation of the world around us
and as its name suggests it's
particularly well attuned to identifying
faces interestingly we find it much
harder to identify faces when they're
upside down because it throws our
pattern recognition off
have a look at the following photos as
you can see they're both headshots of
britain's ex-prime minister margaret
furcher you can also probably see that
there are slight differences between the
two images
but what exactly those differences are
might not be so obvious
until we flip the images upside down to
reveal that one maggie appears to have
been possessed by a demon
this illusion is called the thatcher
effect and it was first illustrated by
professor peter thompson at the
university of york in 1980
it has since been demonstrated with many
other famous figures from barack obama
to adele
okay so that's how our brains process
actual human faces but why is our brain
seeing faces in cars cans and coffee
cups
well data from fmri brain scans seems to
indicate that we use roughly the same
brain regions to identify false faces
as we do real ones
so it seems likely there's some overlap
between the novel mechanisms that enable
us to identify and interpret real human
faces
and those that cause us to see smiles in
our sandwiches
like any visual illusion the extent to
which one experiences facial pariedolia
varies from one person to the next
women seem to see faces in everyday
objects much more often than men
and they also seem to perform better in
facial recognition tests
but researchers disagree as to the
extent of the gender difference and both
genetics and culture may well also play
a part
oddly enough a more consistent predictor
of an individual's ability to see faces
is the extent to which he believes in
religious or paranormal phenomena it
seems people who believe in miracles
will usually be more willing to allow
themselves to see them
at the other extreme are people who are
unable to recognize faces at all
even real ones
this kind of face blindness is known as
facial prosopagnosia
and it affects around 1 in 50 of us
though many of those afflicted don't
even realize it
in case you're wondering i'm the one
with the mustache the condition can be
inherited or caused by brain damage to
the fusiform face area of the brain
while prosopagnosia doesn't seem to
impact general vision
object recognition or memory it can
still have a significant impact on those
who live with it
many of those afflicted struggle to
recognize their own children loved ones
and even
their own reflection
but you don't need to have prosopagnosia
to have experienced that awkward feeling
when you're affectionately greeted like
an old friend by someone you don't
remember ever meeting
that's because most of us can only
recognize about 20
of the faces we've ever encountered
if you're particularly popular it could
be even less
but not everyone is quite so facially
forgetful if anyone's ever smugly told
you they never forget a face
they may actually mean it some
scientists believe there are people out
there who remember up to 95 of the faces
they see
these so-called
super recognizers regularly surpass
computer algorithms in terms of face
processing accuracy
and a few have already been recruited to
help fight crime in cities around the
world
london is one of the most surveilled
cities on the planet with as many as one
cctv camera for every 13 people
but all that privacy invading is only
actually worth it if we can identify the
people we capture committing crimes
enter scotland yard squad of super
recognisers an elite team within the
capital's police force who spends their
days trawling through tens of thousands
of hours of cctv footage
in the hopes of picking out a
perpetrator
they've been involved in several
high-profile cases
including the 2018 salisbury poisoning
and the 2011 london riots
in 2016 alone the then team of six super
recognizers correctly identified 2
500 suspects from a mix of footage and
real-life encounters
they're basically a budget version of
the x-men but even super recognizers
sometimes make mistakes
our brains the so-called most complex
machines in the universe
are almost scarily easy to trick and our
trusty vision is more subjective than
you might think
the way we see the world can be greatly
influenced by the simplest of things
like
lighting focus resolution and
orientation
take a look at these shapes
what do you see
if a ghostly white triangle appears to
be popping out at you from the center
you're not alone
this is what's known as the phantom edge
phenomenon
in other words seeing outlines where
they don't actually exist
the effect is so strong for most people
that it's actually kind of hard to
convince yourself there isn't a triangle
in the center of this image
and it's more than just a quirk of
perception
anything that causes a break in a line
could pose us some unknown threat like a
camouflaged predator lurking in the
shadows so our brain errs on the side of
caution and perceives empty space as an
object
we're particularly sensitive to faces
and even seeing just a pair of eyes can
have a significant psychological impact
on our behavior
for example when images of eyes are put
up near bike racks
bicycle theft decreases by as much as 60
percent
our brains are hardwired to understand
people and their motives which causes us
to look for human-like intentions in
everything around us
exactly what we will see will depend on
our beliefs and experiences
so whilst diane duzia saw the virgin
mary in her 28 thousand dollar toasty
plenty of others saw the heavy eyelids
and parted lips of a much more modern
madonna in that same slice either way
our natural instinct is to see faces
everywhere we look
so next time you see your sandwich
staring back at you
remember you're probably not going crazy
take a few breaths and then pop it on
ebay whilst you're at it because you
never know
one man's toasty is another man's
treasure
thanks for watching
do you really enjoy my content but you
literally can't be asked to use your
eyes
then you're in luck because you can now
listen to the new random interesting
facts podcast with me 42 available on
youtube spotify apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcast you'll
find a link to it in the description
below check it out today and give your
eyes a break
you're welcome